[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  have you been feeling have you been  sleeping any better huh rough then again  I never said well before hoes condition  condition that's cool pregnancy it's  okay to say you have loud some things  happen you need to please rock did you  see some bad  [Applause]  what's going on you can describe seeing  an entity that takes on the form of your  worst fears  we can't stay here every contact we have  had with the outside has brought us  death here kids  they deserve hope every single decision  I have made has been for them listen to  me  you're going on the trip now it's going  to be rough  if you hear something in the woods you  tell me  you hear something in the water you tell  me  but under no circumstance are you  allowed to take off your blindfold  [Applause]  [Music]